Have you ever rearranged your furniture and discovered the carpet underneath looks brand new, while the rest of it looks, well, not so new? It's time for a carpet upgrade. At the Home Depot, we have stylish choices at simple prices from all the top brands. Best of all, we can install it for you, starting at only 49 cents per square foot. So all you have to do is pick your perfect floor. Start your carpet project today at the Home Depot. How doers get more done.
您是否曾经重新布置过家具，却发现地毯下面看起来崭新如初，而其他部分看起来却……没那么新了？是时候升级一下地毯了。在家得宝（The Home Depot），我们以实惠的价格提供来自各大顶级品牌的时尚选择。最棒的是，我们还能为您提供安装服务，每平方英尺仅需49美分起。所以，您只需挑选出您心仪的地板即可。今天就开始您的地毯改造项目吧，就在家得宝。实干者，成大事。
Exclusions apply for licenses, see Home Depot.com slash license numbers. In May, Melinda French Gates announced that she would donate $1 billion to organizations and individuals working to improve the lives of women and girls around the world. As part of that initiative, Gates' Pivotal Ventures Group chose 12 global leaders each to head a $20 million fund in their area of expertise. One of those leaders is Dr. Alfie Breland Noble, a psychologist who has spent decades working to advance the mental health of intersectional youth and youth of color. Today we're going to talk to Dr. Alfie, as she's known, about the state of youth mental health, particularly for youth of color. What are the biggest challenges facing young people today? How has the conversation around youth mental health changed in recent years? And how does she hope to use the new funding to make a difference in the lives of young people?
许可相关条款适用，详情请见HomeDepot.com/license-numbers。今年五月，梅琳达·弗兰奇·盖茨（Melinda French Gates）宣布，她将捐赠10亿美元，用于支持那些致力于改善全球妇女和女童生活的组织与个人。作为该倡议的一部分，盖茨的Pivotal Ventures集团选出了12位全球领袖，每人负责管理其专业领域内的一项2000万美元基金。其中一位领袖是阿尔菲·布里兰·诺布尔（Dr. Alfie Breland Noble）博士，她是一位心理学家，几十年来一直致力于提升交叉性群体青年和有色人种青年的心理健康。今天，我们将与大家熟知的阿尔菲博士探讨青年心理健康的现状，特别是针对有色人种青年的心理健康问题。当今年轻人面临的最大挑战是什么？近年来关于青年心理健康的对话发生了怎样的变化？她又希望如何利用这笔新资金来改善年轻人的生活？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today, as I mentioned, is Dr. Alfie Breland Noble, a psychologist, scientist, author, mental health correspondent, and founder of the mental health nonprofit, the Acoma Project. A thought leader in her field, Dr. Alfie focuses on mental health and suicide prevention for intersectional youth and young adults of color. Dr. Alfie holds a PhD in counseling psychology.
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会（APA）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。正如我刚才提到的，今天的嘉宾是阿尔菲·布里兰·诺布尔博士，她是一位心理学家、科学家、作家、心理健康通讯员，也是心理健康非营利组织“Acoma项目”（The Acoma Project）的创始人。作为该领域的思想领袖，阿尔菲博士专注于交叉性群体青年和有色人种年轻人的心理健康与自杀预防。阿尔菲博士拥有咨询心理学博士学位。
Before founding the nonprofit Acoma Project, she spent nearly two decades. AIDS in academia as a professor at Duke University and Georgetown University. She's a sought-after public speaker and a regular media contributor to outlets including the Grio, the Today Show, and the New York Times. She hosts the Odyssey Radio's Suicide Prevention Special I'm Listening with Carson Daly and Katie Neal and co-hosted the Born This Way Foundation's World Kindness Day short film, The Power of Kindness with Lady Gaga. Dr. Alfie, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me. What a great introduction. There was so much to say about you.
在创立非营利组织Acoma项目之前，她在学术界担任了近二十年的教授，曾任职于杜克大学和乔治城大学。她是一位广受欢迎的公众演说家，也是包括《The Grio》、NBC《今日秀》（Today Show）和《纽约时报》在内的多家媒体的常驻撰稿人。她主持了奥德赛电台（Odyssey Radio）的自杀预防特别节目《我在倾听》（I'm Listening，与卡森·戴利和凯蒂·尼尔合作），并与Lady Gaga共同主持了“天生完美基金会”（Born This Way Foundation）的世界善良日短片《善良的力量》（The Power of Kindness）。阿尔菲博士，感谢您今天能来参加节目。谢谢您的邀请，这真是一个很棒的介绍。关于您的成就，确实有太多可以说的了。
But let's start with this new recognition and the $20 million fund you will be leading. It's a life-changing amount of money. What was it like to get that call and had you applied for it or was it a total surprise? This is an easy question to answer. It was a complete, utter and total surprise, number one. and I got an email and it was mind-blowing. I wasn't sure it was real until I had an opportunity to communicate with the colleague who was like, yes, it's very real.
但我们先从这次新的认可和您将领导的2000万美元基金谈起吧。这是一笔足以改变人生的巨款。接到那个电话时是什么感觉？您之前申请过吗，还是完全是个惊喜？这个问题很好回答。第一，这完全、彻底、绝对是一个惊喜。我收到了一封电子邮件，当时简直惊呆了。直到我有机会与一位同事沟通，对方确认“是的，这是真的”，我才敢相信。
This is not spam. And at that point, it was just kind of, I felt like my world sort of exploded. What I like to say to people is I imagine that it's something like what happens when people get the call for the MacArthur, you know, what they call them, the Genius Award. It's sort of like, right? So McArthur is a one amount, but you've already shared with this, $20 million. And it's like, wait, what? For who? Who you talking to? You sure you got the right person? So it was mind-blowing, to say the least. Yeah. Well, we'll talk more about that fund a little
这不是垃圾邮件。那一刻，我感觉我的世界仿佛炸开了。我喜欢对别人说，我想这就像人们接到麦克阿瑟奖（MacArthur Fellowship）电话时的感觉，也就是人们常说的“天才奖”。就是那种感觉，对吧？麦克阿瑟奖是一笔金额，但你们刚才分享了，这是2000万美元。当时我就想，等等，什么？给谁？你们在跟谁说话？你们确定找对人了吗？所以，至少可以说，这简直令人难以置信。是的。好吧，我们稍后再详细谈谈那笔基金。
later. But first, I want to ask you about the work you've been doing with the ACOMA project over the past several years. So how did it start? And what kind of work does the project do? All right. So I'll start with the second question first, because that's really easy. My elevator pitch for the ACOMA project is we are an organization at 501c3 nonprofit, which as a black woman, and a black woman leader in the nonprofit space was very important to me for the independence, obviously with the checks and balances that a 501C3 provides, as opposed to as many people in your audience will know,
但首先，我想问问您过去几年在Acoma项目所做的工作。它是如何开始的？该项目主要做什么工作？好的，我先回答第二个问题，因为这很简单。我对Acoma项目的电梯演讲是：我们是一个501(c)(3)非营利组织。作为一名黑人女性，同时也是非营利领域的一名黑人女性领导者，独立性对我来说非常重要，当然是在501(c)(3)所提供的制衡机制下，而不是像你们听众中许多人所知道的那样，
a fiscally sponsored organization, nothing wrong with that, but it was important for me for a coma to be a 501c3. Before that, a coma was my research lab. So as you shared, I spent the bulk of my career in academic medicine in departments of psychiatry. So at Duke, because I was in the department of psychiatry. And at Georgetown, I was in the department of psychiatry. And I was a health disparities researcher.
一个由财政资助的组织。这本身没什么问题，但对我来说，Acoma成为一个501(c)(3)组织非常重要。在此之前，Acoma是我的研究实验室。正如您所分享的，我的大部分职业生涯是在学术医学界的精神病学系度过的。在杜克大学时，我在精神病学系；在乔治城大学时，我同样在精神病学系。我是一名健康差异研究员。
So Accoma's three pillars are raising consciousness, empowering people, and changing the system of mental health. And really, all of that has to do with creating and finding space for young people of color. And when I talk about young people of color, I'm talking about youth, young adults, the families and communities that they are a part of because no child exists in isolation. And there are also people with multiple identities. So our young people might be LGBTQAI plus and of color. They might have a disability and be of color. They might be all of those things together. So at a coma, we're really about finding and creating space without taking up space
因此，Acoma的三大支柱是：提高意识、赋能于人、改变心理健康体系。实际上，这一切都与为有色人种年轻人创造和寻找空间有关。当我谈到有色人种年轻人时，我指的是青年、年轻人，以及他们所属的家庭和社区，因为没有任何孩子是孤立存在的。他们也是拥有多重身份的人。所以我们的年轻人可能是LGBTQAI+群体，同时也是有色人种；他们可能身患残疾，同时也是有色人种；他们可能同时具备所有这些身份。因此，在Acoma，我们真正要做的是寻找和创造空间，而不是从我们的年轻人那里
from our young people to train them, to collaborate with them, to learn from them, and to empower them to find and create space for themselves within the conversations on mental health and not just find space, but to be centered and uplifted and empowered to know and to recognize that their mental health is important. So that's what the Accoma project is. We do programming. I am a researcher at heart. So we do research. The state of mental health of youth of color was a seminal report that we put out, 2022 and 2023. And that's, who we are and what we do. Then in terms of, you know, this being like a critical, important part of my career in my life, like I said, when I started, I was an academic medicine and what became
抢占空间。我们要培训他们，与他们合作，向他们学习，并赋予他们力量，让他们在心理健康对话中找到并创造属于自己的空间。不仅是找到空间，还要让他们成为中心，得到提升，并有能力认识到他们的心理健康非常重要。这就是Acoma项目。我们开展项目，我本质上是一名研究员，所以我们也做研究。《有色人种青年心理健康现状》是我们2022年和2023年发布的一份开创性报告。这就是我们是谁，我们做什么。至于这是否是我职业生涯和生活中至关重要的一部分，正如我所说，当我开始时，我是在学术医学界，后来我
apparent to me was that there was flexibility that I needed to do this work that I wasn't going to be able to find in traditional academic medicine. So we took that research lab, turned it into a 501c3, and we've just had the wonderful fortune of having somebody like Melinda French Gates see me, and see our work at a coma and say, we want to support this. We want to promote this. And we want to give a person like Dr. Althean opportunity to go out there and do for other people what she was able to do for herself, which is carve out a space to do like boots on the ground work for a community that is too underserved, too overlooked, too often not centered in conversations
意识到，我需要一种灵活性来开展这项工作，而这种灵活性在传统的学术医学界是无法获得的。于是，我们将那个研究实验室转变为一个501(c)(3)组织，并且非常幸运地得到了像梅琳达·弗兰奇·盖茨这样的人的认可，她看到了我和我们在Acoma的工作，并表示：“我们想支持这一点，我们想推广这一点。”我们想给像阿尔菲博士这样的人一个机会，去为其他人做她能够为自己做的事情，那就是开辟一个空间，为一个太缺乏服务、太被忽视、太常在心理健康对话中被边缘化的群体，开展脚踏实地的实地工作。
around mental health. And when you do this research, are you just publishing it yourself? or are you going through the peer review process, or you're going to journals, or you're just putting it out there because people need it. We do all of the above, right? And so in our field, like I always joke,
当您进行这项研究时，是您自己发表，还是通过同行评审流程，或者投给期刊，还是仅仅因为人们需要它就发布出来？我们以上所有方式都会采用，对吧？在我们的领域，就像我常开玩笑说的那样，
I'm a liberated academic. I was an APA convention over the weekend, and I said that. And people kind of know what I mean as soon as I say it, like being a liberated attorney. I have a lot of friends who say, yeah, I'm a liberated attorney.
我是一个“解放了的学者”。周末我在APA大会上说了这句话。人们一听就明白我的意思，就像“解放了的律师”一样。我有很多朋友说：“是的，我是一名解放了的律师。”
So for us, there are multiple audiences that we're speaking to, and I can't tell you how elated I am to have the opportunity. I'm so grateful to my team, Catalina and other folks for helping put this together because psychology and APA has always been important to me. I've been in APA since the 90s, like the early 90s. And, you know, I've been able to at different points in time find a home within APA. And so I just want to, I have to say how important
所以对我们来说，我们面对的是多个受众。我无法用言语表达我有多么高兴能有这个机会。我非常感谢我的团队，卡塔琳娜和其他帮助促成此事的人，因为心理学和APA对我来说一直很重要。我从90年代，也就是90年代初就开始加入APA了。而且，你知道，我在不同的时间点都能在APA找到归属感。所以我只想说，
and meaningful it is for me to be here in this moment. So when I think about, you know, how important this work is and why we do this work and how valuable this work is, it's just really important to me for everybody to understand and recognize that who they are in their core being is perfect as is and that over time what we're looking for is for them to grow into more perfect versions of themselves. So when I'm publishing, I want to reach people where they are. So you have young people, they're not reading peer-viewed journals unless maybe they're in grad school, right? When you have our academic peers, they're not reading generally what lay people are reading. The gravitas, right, your bona fides come from what?
此时此刻能在这里对我来说是多么重要和有意义。所以，当我思考这项工作有多么重要，为什么我们要做这项工作，以及这项工作有多么宝贵时，对我来说最重要的是让每个人都理解并认识到，他们核心的自我本身就是完美的，随着时间的推移，我们所追求的是让他们成长为更完美的自己。所以当我发表文章时，我想在人们所在的地方接触到他们。年轻人可能不会阅读同行评审的期刊，除非他们是在读研究生，对吧？而我们的学术同行，通常也不会阅读普通大众所读的内容。权威性，也就是你的资历，来自于什么？
Peer review publications. I was a journal editor for a while. I have multiple books that I've edited. I have three books out, two are edited. One is co-authored with a music producer, who's a phenomenal human being. So we put our work out everywhere. So it's on our website. We put information out on socials.
同行评审的出版物。我曾担任过一段时间的期刊编辑。我编辑过好几本书。我有三本书出版，其中两本是编辑的。一本是与一位音乐制作人合著的，他是一个了不起的人。所以我们将我们的工作发布在各个地方。它在我们的网站上，我们在社交媒体上发布信息。
I have multiple peer review, many peer review, probably over 50 peer review publications. As I said, the books. And we have a newsletter. So our information gets disseminated in all these places because, again, the goal is to center and acknowledge and recognize people who are often left out of these conversations. So we have to go places beyond just peer-reviewed journal publications. Now, intersectionality is key to the Accoma Project's mission. Can you talk more about what that means? What exactly is intersectionality for our listeners?
我有许多同行评审的出版物，大概超过50篇。正如我所说，还有那些书。我们还有一份时事通讯。所以我们的信息在所有这些地方传播，因为再次强调，目标是让那些经常被排除在这些对话之外的人成为中心，并得到认可。所以我们必须去往同行评审期刊之外的地方。现在，交叉性是Acoma项目使命的关键。您能多谈谈这意味着什么吗？对于我们的听众来说，交叉性到底是什么？
Why is it important to consider it in the context of mental health and well-being? Oh, that's a wonderful question. So I always let the opportunity to shout out scholars with marginalized identities. And the sister, professor, Kimberly Crenshaw, an attorney from out in California, is the person who coined the term. And for her, it really was, as I understand it, an outgrowth of recognizing, particularly for her as a black woman, which I also am African American by ethnicity and culture, that we don't ever, just exists as women or as black people. We're both at the same time. So there are these intersections. And people have taken that and have really blown that concept up. But all praise goes to Kimberly Crenshaw, Professor Crenshaw, for being the first one to put it out there.
为什么在心理健康和福祉的背景下考虑它很重要？哦，这是一个非常好的问题。我总是喜欢借此机会向那些具有边缘化身份的学者致敬。金伯利·克伦肖（Kimberlé Crenshaw）教授，一位来自加州的律师，是创造这个术语的人。据我理解，对她来说，这实际上是认识到——特别是对她作为一名黑人女性而言，我也是一名非裔美国人，在种族和文化上——我们从来不仅仅是以女性或黑人的身份存在。我们同时是这两者。所以存在这些交叉点。人们采纳了这个概念并将其发扬光大。但所有的赞誉都应归于金伯利·克伦肖教授，感谢她第一个将其提出来。
And so how it shows up at the Accoma Project, I'll give you a great example. From our state of mental health of youth of color report, the full report, which we put out in 2023, we were able to look at African-American, black American young people who can be, from families that have immigrated from the Caribbean or the continent of Africa or black Latinos,
那么它在Acoma项目是如何体现的呢？我给您举个很好的例子。根据我们2023年发布的《有色人种青年心理健康现状》完整报告，我们能够观察到非裔美国人、黑人美国青年，他们可能来自从加勒比海或非洲大陆移民的家庭，或者是黑人拉丁裔、
Latino-Latine folks, Native American, Asian-American Pacific Islander, and people who primarily identify as multiracial. Those are the racial ethnic groups that we included in our sample. That gives us the ability to talk about intersectionality, right? Because how often do people talk about multiracial people as an ethnic group? By the same token, we have data on trans girls and trans girls' experience of dealing with their mental health, depression, anxiety, exposure to racial trauma, the experience of COVID.
拉丁裔/拉丁美洲裔、美洲原住民、亚裔美国人及太平洋岛民，以及主要认同为多种族的人。这些是我们样本中包含的种族族裔群体。这使我们有能力谈论交叉性，对吧？因为人们多久会谈论多种族人群作为一个族裔群体呢？同样地，我们也有关于跨性别女孩的数据，以及跨性别女孩在处理心理健康、抑郁、焦虑、遭受种族创伤、新冠疫情经历方面的经验。
That's not the kind of data that we typically see in our field. We will either see a story or a journal article that talks about queer youth, right, LGBTQAI plus youth, or it talks about youth in generally is black, white, and Latino. That's generally how people will, everybody else gets shoved into other. Intersectionality doesn't believe in another. Intersectionality says everybody's identity is important, and that's how. we try to make it visible at the Accoma project in our work. No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets.
这不是我们领域通常看到的那种数据。我们通常会看到一个故事或一篇期刊文章，要么谈论酷儿青年，即LGBTQAI+青年，要么谈论黑人、白人和拉丁裔青年。这通常是人们的做法，其他人全被塞进了“其他”类别。交叉性不相信“其他”。交叉性认为每个人的身份都很重要，这就是我们在Acoma项目的研究中努力使其可见的方式。没人会因为电子表格去汉克（Hank's）披萨店。
They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks co-pilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs and help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work. Now, Hanks has a line out the door.
他们去是因为那里的披萨确实好吃。但最近店里很冷清。于是汉克决定重新推出1美元一片的披萨。他让微软Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本，看看他是否负担得起。Copilot向汉克展示了钱花在了哪里，以及哪些小细节能让1美元披萨的方案行得通。现在，汉克店门口排起了长队。
Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheet. Learn more at M365 copilot.com slash work. Let's get back to that amazing grant from Melinda French Gates. Now, do you get that money all at once or is it spread out over time? So the way it's set up is we have a year to push that money out. And as soon as we're ready to hit go, we're still in the process of getting up and running with the funds. All of us are, all dozen of the people who are doing this.
汉克做披萨，Copilot处理电子表格。了解更多信息，请访问M365copilot.com/work。让我们回到梅琳达·弗兰奇·盖茨那笔惊人的拨款。这笔钱是一次性给您的，还是分期发放的？它的设置方式是，我们有一年的时间来发放这笔钱。一旦我们准备好启动，我们目前还在筹备资金运作的过程中。我们所有人，所有负责此事的十几个人都是如此。
And so it'll be over the course of the next year that you will see this start. start to work and to go out there into the public. But we haven't fully, fully finished the background checks and everything that we need to do to get everything set up fully. We're still working on getting set up and running, but we have a year to get it out. And you have set up this organization called the Maddie Fund to distribute the money, right? Can you talk about that? Why is it called the Maddie Fund?
所以，在接下来的一年里，您会看到这项工作开始启动并进入公众视野。但我们还没有完全完成背景调查和所有需要做的事情来全面建立一切。我们仍在努力筹备和运行，但我们有一年的时间来发放它。您已经成立了一个名为“Maddie基金”的组织来分发这笔钱，对吗？您能谈谈这个吗？为什么叫Maddie基金？
And what kind of work in organizations will you be looking to support through it? So the Maddie Fund is an acronym. It stands for mindful advocacy for totally transformative inclusion and equity. So if anybody who knows me know, I'm all about diversity, equity, and inclusion. Those are golden words to me. Those are not bad words to me. They're very important. And Maddie is an acronym, as I said, but the name is my mother's name.
您希望通过它支持什么样的组织和工作？Maddie基金是一个首字母缩写。它代表“为彻底的包容性和公平性进行的正念倡导”（Mindful Advocacy for Totally Transformative Inclusion and Equity）。所以任何了解我的人都知道，我非常支持多元、公平和包容（DEI）。这些对我来说是金科玉律。它们不是坏词，它们非常重要。Maddie是一个缩写，正如我所说，但这个名字是我母亲的名字。
My mom passed away from pancreatic cancer 18 years ago in September. And she was a person who loved everybody even before it was cool. So my mom, they have this organization called Best Buddies. and many people are familiar with. And Best Buddies focuses on young people with disabilities and partnering them with people who don't have disabilities and inclusion. My mom was taking care of young people and supporting young people with disabilities before anybody knew what the Best Buddies was.
我母亲在18年前的九月因胰腺癌去世了。她是一个在这些理念流行之前就爱所有人的那种人。我母亲，他们有一个组织叫“最佳伙伴”（Best Buddies），很多人都很熟悉。Best Buddies专注于残疾年轻人，并将他们与没有残疾的人配对，促进包容。我母亲在任何人知道Best Buddies是什么之前，就已经在照顾和支持残疾年轻人了。
By the same token, my mother was what we call an ally now before we knew what an ally was. I remember growing up and she had queer black students to mentor my brother and me. And so it gave me the opportunity through watching how my mom worked, walk through the world and how inclusive and loving she was to also incorporate that and to honor her legacy in the work that I do. And so my focus obviously is going to be on mental health and emotional well-being with a focus, as Melinda French Gates has said, focusing primarily on women and girls of diverse backgrounds.
同样地，我母亲在我们知道什么是“盟友”之前，就是我们现在所说的盟友。我记得在成长过程中，她有酷儿黑人学生来指导我和我哥哥。所以，通过观察我母亲如何工作、如何行走于世，以及她有多么包容和充满爱心，我也能够将这些融入到我的工作中，并以此来纪念她的遗产。因此，我的重点显然将放在心理健康和情感福祉上，正如梅琳达·弗兰奇·盖茨所说，主要关注不同背景的妇女和女童。
But of course, if you're going to focus on women and girls, you also have to talk to the men and non-binary people and boys who love them, who are a part of their lives. And so that's what the work is going to be, looking for people out there working really hard and grinding to create equity in the mental health and emotional well-being space for diverse people, diverse young people in particular. How will the Maddie Fund find these recipients? And then when they get the money, do they apply for it and do they have to tell you how they're going to use it? Is this for education? Is this for other reasons that people might need money? So we're interested in organizations where they can demonstrate.
但当然，如果你要关注妇女和女童，你也必须与爱她们、作为她们生活一部分的男性、非二元性别者和男孩进行对话。所以这就是这项工作的内容，寻找那些在心理健康和情感福祉领域努力工作、为多元化人群，特别是多元化年轻人创造公平的人。Maddie基金将如何找到这些受助者？当他们拿到钱后，他们需要申请吗？他们必须告诉您他们将如何使用这笔钱吗？这是用于教育，还是人们可能需要钱的其他原因？我们对那些能够证明的组织感兴趣，
through their work, whatever kind of work it is, a commitment to centering, not just including, but centering and uplifting diverse young people in their mental health. That is the core. We're not in a place where we're opening a formal application process at this stage. We're not doing that.
通过他们的工作，无论是什么样的工作，他们都致力于将多元化的年轻人置于心理健康工作的中心，不仅仅是包含，而是中心化和提升。这是核心。我们目前还没有开放正式的申请流程。我们没有这样做。
I'm not sure that we will. But in terms of how are we going to identify organizations, our goal is to identify these organizations organically through personal outreach and through extending our networks beyond just the people we know. So I don't want it to be just a snowball effect that the people we reach are the friends of the friends of the friends. I think there are other ways that we're working on sourcing
我不确定我们是否会这样做。但就我们如何识别组织而言，我们的目标是通过个人外联和将我们的网络扩展到我们认识的人之外，有机地识别这些组织。所以我不想让它仅仅产生滚雪球效应，即我们接触到的人只是朋友的朋友的朋友。我认为我们正在努力寻找其他方式来寻找
and determining of how do we reach people who are underrepresented who nobody else is paying attention to, right? Now, some of that, because I do have a marginalized identity and because I am a person who runs an organization that's focused on these communities, I will already know some organizations that other folks don't know. But I'm also clear, I don't know everybody.
并确定我们如何接触到那些代表性不足、没人关注的人，对吧？现在，其中一些，因为我确实有边缘化的身份，而且我经营着一个专注于这些社区的组织，所以我已经会知道一些其他人不知道的组织。但我也很清楚，我并不认识所有人。
I don't know everything. So there are people and entities and organizations I won't have visibility of where I want to figure out how do we get to those folks because the goal is to reach way out into the margins for people doing good work and to bring them into the center to uplift and support them
我并不了解一切。所以有一些人、实体和组织是我无法看到的，我想弄清楚如何找到这些人，因为目标是深入边缘地带，寻找那些做着好工作的人，并将他们带到中心，提升和支持他们，
because they're doing good work for the communities that they serve. So it's all organization to organization, so it's not Maddie fund to individuals. Is that correct? Correct. I don't think we'll be funding any individuals. There's been a lot of discussion of a mental health crisis among young people in the last few years. And interestingly, recently CDC released new data found a slight improvement in young people's mental health since 2021, including among young people of color. but the rates of persistent sadness and suicide attempts were down slightly among girls, though they were still high compared to 10 years ago. I'm curious whether you think that we're still in a mental health crisis right now, and if so, how much of that is due to the after effects of the pandemic and how much to other factors?
因为他们为所服务的社区做了很好的工作。所以这都是组织对组织，不是Maddie基金对个人，对吗？没错。我不认为我们会资助任何个人。过去几年，关于年轻人心理健康危机的讨论很多。有趣的是，最近CDC发布的新数据显示，自2021年以来，年轻人的心理健康状况略有改善，包括有色人种青年。但女孩中持续悲伤和自杀企图的比率略有下降，尽管与10年前相比仍然很高。我很好奇，您是否认为我们现在仍处于心理健康危机中？如果是的话，其中有多少是由于疫情的后遗症，又有多少是由于其他因素？
I think we're still in the midst of a crisis, a mental health crisis. I remember hearing Dr. Arthur Evans talk about an endemic or something he called it. It was three things happening at once, right? The fight for social justice, COVID, and this mental health crisis. So all these things have converged. I don't see those things going away anytime. If anything, what I see is more willingness to talk about these issues. And this is a critical distinction.
我认为我们仍处于危机之中，一场心理健康危机。我记得听过亚瑟·埃文斯（Dr. Arthur Evans）博士谈论一种“地方性流行病”或他称之为类似的东西。这是三件事同时发生，对吧？争取社会正义的斗争、新冠疫情，以及这场心理健康危机。所以所有这些事情都汇聚在一起了。我没看到这些事情会很快消失。如果说有什么变化的话，我看到的是人们更愿意谈论这些问题了。这是一个关键的区别。
What I'm not seeing is a huge uptick uptick in communities of color of people seeking care. One, I don't know that we have measured it accurately. I don't know if we've measured it at all looking specifically at marginalized communities. So we can talk about representative samples, but remember, you know, for what is worth, representative samples means that the vast majority of the sample, probably 50 to 60 percent of that sample is going to be white. There's nothing wrong with that, but it means if we're lumping everybody else into 40% of the sample and there are small numbers based on people's representation in the population,
我没有看到有色人种社区中寻求护理的人数有大幅增加。第一，我不知道我们是否准确地衡量了这一点。我不知道我们是否专门针对边缘化社区进行了衡量。所以我们可以谈论代表性样本，但请记住，无论价值如何，代表性样本意味着样本的绝大多数，可能50%到60%的样本将是白人。这没什么错，但这意味着如果我们把其他人归入样本的40%，并且基于人们在人口中的代表性，人数很少，
then you're going to have some folks in these studies where their ethnic group is, teeny tiny, 2%, 1%, so we need to know more. So I think, I don't think we know. And I do think that this critical distinction I'm making is while we talk about it, do we see, can we identify whether or not everybody is increasing in the right proportions based on need versus actually receiving the support that then you? I'm not sure that we're there. And I think stigma, the argument would be the stigma has reduced. I think it has. Some, somewhat. But when you look across generations, I would not argue that stigma has reduced drastically because I'm Gen X. So you look at Gen X and baby boomers, I'm not sure the stigma
那么你在这些研究中就会有一些人，他们的族裔群体非常小，2%、1%，所以我们需要知道更多。所以我认为，我不认为我们知道。而且我确实认为我所做的这个关键区别是，虽然我们谈论它，但我们是否能确定每个人是否根据需求在增加，而不是真正获得了他们需要的支持？我不确定我们是否达到了这一点。而且我认为污名化，论点可能是污名化已经减少了。我认为确实减少了。一些，在某种程度上。但当你跨代观察时，我不会说污名化已经大幅减少，因为我是X世代。所以你看看X世代和婴儿潮一代，我不确定污名化
has reduced that much. And we're the parents and grandparents of the kids who are clamoring and fighting for. We need more mental health support. So I think the jury is still out. Here's a broad question. What do you believe, based on the work that you do, are the biggest mental health challenges facing young people today and youth of color in particular? I'll start with youth of color. I think the biggest challenge is that we as the adults who love them and care for them don't do a good enough job of either preparing our young people with the plethora of coping skills that they will need to navigate the society that they're in now, including navigating,
减少了那么多。而我们正是那些呼吁和争取“我们需要更多心理健康支持”的孩子们的父母和祖父母。所以我认为结论尚无定论。这是一个广泛的问题。根据您的工作，您认为当今年轻人，特别是有色人种青年，面临的最大心理健康挑战是什么？我先从有色人种青年说起。我认为最大的挑战是，我们作为爱他们、关心他们的成年人，在准备工作上做得不够好，没有为我们的年轻人提供他们在这个社会中导航所需的丰富应对技能，包括导航，
taking care of their mental health, number one. And number two, I don't think we talk about the social injustices that our young people face enough. We don't talk about it enough. And I think when you look at data, it's new for a lot of internet. Now, we've been doing this at the Coma Project since we started. So you're talking about 20-something years. The challenge is really, we don't talk about those things enough in the literature.
照顾好他们的心理健康，这是第一点。第二点，我认为我们谈论我们的年轻人所面临的社会不公还不够多。我们谈论得不够。而且我认为当你观察数据时，这对很多互联网来说是新的。现在，我们在Acoma项目从开始就一直在做这件事。所以你谈论的是20多年。挑战确实是，我们在文献中谈论这些事情不够多。
So we're missing a whole chunk of the lived experience of young people of color because we don't talk about these things. So, you know, for me, that's a critical inflection point. Until we have those conversations in there full, I think we're going to be. behind the eight ball, so to speak, in terms of really being able to understand what is it that our young people are dealing with and where are the points where we can go in and help. I just want to see the data get better and catch up to the actual world that we live in, not the representative sample world that we think we live in. I want to talk for a minute about the role of social media, which has become so pervasive in all of our lives, and how it affects young people's mental health.
所以我们错过了一大块有色人种青年的生活经验，因为我们不谈论这些事情。所以，对我来说，这是一个关键的转折点。除非我们进行充分的对话，否则我认为我们将处于劣势，无法真正理解我们的年轻人正在处理什么，以及我们可以在哪些方面介入并提供帮助。我只是想看到数据变得更好，并赶上我们生活的真实世界，而不是我们认为我们生活的那个代表性样本世界。我想花点时间谈谈社交媒体的作用，它已经渗透到我们所有人的生活中，以及它如何影响年轻人的心理健康。
Is it, in your view, is social media more of a problem for young people's mental health? Or is it something that's good that keeps them connected? I think it's both. So I had the great fortune of working with the Surgeon General who put out the advisory earlier this year. I think Dr. Vivek Murthy is phenomenal in terms of how he's out front on these issues of mental health and mental illness, particularly for our young people. I will also say that I'm not sure that we know fully what all the positive benefits are. I think we have ideas and what all the negative detractors are in terms of social media. I think that there's room for both.
在您看来，社交媒体对年轻人的心理健康来说是一个更大的问题吗？还是说它是一件好事，能让他们保持联系？我认为两者兼而有之。我有幸与今年早些时候发布咨询报告的卫生局局长合作。我认为维韦克·默西（Dr. Vivek Murthy）博士在心理健康和精神疾病问题上，特别是针对我们年轻人的问题上，表现得非常出色。我也要说，我不确定我们是否完全了解所有的积极益处。我认为我们有一些想法，以及社交媒体在负面干扰方面的情况。我认为两者都有空间。
I think you phrase it perfectly. There are ways in which social media allows people to have connection. I think in particular about queer kids, LGBTIQA plus young people. sometimes home is not safe the physical home is not safe but that device is safe because I can connect with people who understand me who can give me advice who can support me who know what's going on in my life because they're going through the same thing or they have gone through it and it creates representation you know young people always talk about representation matters that's true you need to see people who look like you succeeding to know that you can succeed too I think on the downside it comes back
我认为您表达得很完美。社交媒体在某些方面让人们能够建立联系。我特别想到酷儿孩子，LGBTQAI+年轻人。有时家庭并不安全，物理上的家庭并不安全，但那个设备是安全的，因为我可以与理解我的人联系，他们可以给我建议，可以支持我，他们知道我生活中发生了什么，因为他们正在经历同样的事情，或者他们已经经历过了。它创造了代表性，你知道年轻人总是谈论“代表性很重要”，这是真的。你需要看到像你一样的人成功，才能知道你也能成功。我认为在负面方面，它回到了
to those coping skills if we don't help set healthy boundaries because we as caregivers and parents don't have healthy boundaries with our relationship to social media, we can't model for young people what those healthy boundaries need to look like. And that in and of itself becomes a problem. So I really think it's both. I think we're still trying to figure out how do we manage both the algorithm in terms of what it feeds us and how do we manage taking care of our brains and our brain health so that we don't get caught up in the algorithm and we don't get caught up in those cues and the psychology that
那些应对技能。如果我们不帮助设定健康的界限，因为我们作为照顾者和父母，与社交媒体的关系本身就没有健康的界限，我们就无法为年轻人树立这些健康界限应该是什么样子的榜样。这本身就成了一个问题。所以我真的认为两者兼而有之。我认为我们仍在试图弄清楚我们如何管理算法在喂养我们什么，以及我们如何管理照顾我们的大脑和大脑健康，这样我们就不会被算法所困，也不会被那些不断把我们拉回社交媒体使用的线索和心理学所困。所以我认为我们还有很长的路要走，但我认为它对我们的年轻人来说既有积极的一面，也有消极的一面。您是否看到有色人种青年和白人孩子在使用社交媒体的方式上有什么不同？还是说都一样？我不确定是否都一样。同样，这是那个问题。我不认为我们观察得足够多。我所知道的是，皮尤研究中心（Pew Charitable Trust）多年前的数据显示，超过80%的黑人和拉丁裔孩子拥有智能手机，相比之下，白人孩子拥有智能手机的比例较低，我应该澄清一下，对吧？
keeps pulling us back into the use of social media. So I think we have a ways to go, but I think it has both positive and negative sides to it for our young people. Do you see any differences between young people of color and white kids in the way that they're using social media? Or is it all the same? I'm not sure it's all the same. Again, that's the question. I don't think we've looked at enough. What I do know is that data, I remember this data from Pew Charitable Trust years ago that said that over 80% of black and Latino Latino, Latin A kids have smartphones compared to white kids, compared to a lower number of white kids, I should say, to clarify, right?
所以这些有色人种的孩子，他们在使用这些设备。他们在不同的社会经济阶层中都拥有这些设备。我认为这意味着几乎可以肯定，他们在参与方式上会有所不同。我认为同样，我们不知道这个问题的确切答案，因为我不确定有谁深入研究过它。有一位姐妹，伯尼西亚（Bernicia），我想她的名字是布林迪莎·泰姆斯（Brindisha Times），在加州，
So these children of color, they are on these devices. They have these devices across socioeconomic strata. I think that that means almost by definition, they're going to be differences in terms of how they're engaging. I think as well, we don't know the answer to this definitively, because I'm not sure who studied it like intensively. There's a sister out, Bernicia, I think her name is Brindisha Times out in California
她是一位研究有色人种儿童社交媒体使用的教授。我相信我见过她谈论过。我知道从我们的数据中可以肯定，有色人种青年正在遭遇骚扰，种族骚扰、基于性别认同的骚扰、基于LGBTQAI+身份的骚扰，其程度与他们的白人同龄人不同。因为请记住，你还有另一层。
who's a professor who studies social media use among kids of color. And I believe I've seen her talk about. I know this is the case from our data that young people of color are encountering harassment, racial harassment, gender identity-based harassment, LGBTQ-A-I-plus harassment at different levels than their white peers. because remember, you have another layer.
所以如果你不是白人，在你的性别认同或酷儿身份或除了种族之外的任何身份之上，还有另一层。当你加上种族，当你加上文化，当你加上移民身份，当你加上语言——英语可能不是你的第一语言——这增加了层次。所以我们在数据中发现，我们所有年轻人中约有18%到20%，
So if you're something other than white, there's another layer on top of your gender identity or your queer identity or whatever that identity might be other than race. When you add race to it, when you add culture to it, when you add maybe immigration status to it, when you add language, English may not be your first language, that adds layers. And so what we found in our data was about 18 to 20% of all of our young people,
不是一次事件，而是报告在一年中定期经历种族骚扰。我不知道白人青年的数据是多少，因为我不知道有人研究过那个。所以我可以说我们知道有一些数据告诉我们存在差异。我不知道我们是否有大量的数据。你知道我们在我们领域的情况。如果它没有印刷出来，它就不存在。它没有回归分析，它就没有意义。我不知道我们是否有足够的数据能够断言我们确定存在这些白人孩子和有色人种孩子之间的显著差异，但我们知道确实存在一些差异。
not one incident, but report general experiences over the course of a year. periodically with racial harassment. I don't know what that data is for white young people, because I don't know that anybody studied that. So I would say we know that there's some data there to tell us that there are differences. I don't know that we have a preponderance of data. You know how we are in our field. If it's not in print, it doesn't exist. It doesn't have a regression. It doesn't mean anything. I don't know that we have enough data to be able to say definitively that we know for certain that there are these significant differences between white kids and kids of color, but we know there are some differences.
您想通过Acoma项目和您能够收集的数据研究的下一个问题是什么？我想补充的最重要的一点是，我们没有，我们在第一轮研究中未能增加一个阿拉伯/中东/北非（MENA）人口子样本。所以我们将在下一轮研究中纠正这一点。你知道，在这种气候下，与北非和中东有联系的年轻人，我不知道我们是否知道这些年轻人的经历，特别是当你考虑到该地区的人在美国是如何被分类的历史时。我记得在
What are the next questions that you want to study through the Acoma project and the data that you're able to collect? The biggest thing I want to add is we did not, we failed in not adding an Arab Mina population subsample to our first iteration of the study. So we're going to rectify that with the next iteration of the study. You know, in this climate, young people who have ties, you know, to North Africa and the Middle East, I don't know that we know what these young folks' experiences, particularly when you think about the history of how people from that region are classified in the United States. I can remember being
研究生院时，有一位来自中东的兄弟。他告诉我，请记住，那是90年代，他给自己贴上了标签，因为这是他们在人口普查中被鼓励的方式，即“白人”。但他有非常不同的经历，而且他看起来并不像白人。他在这个国家经历的种族体验与那些看起来确实像白人的人非常不同。所以我认为我们现在已经超越了这一点。有一位我几年前指导过的同事，名叫吉吉·阿瓦德（Dr. Gigi Awad）博士。我想她在密歇根大学。她是一位中东女性。她对此研究很多。
in graduate school with a brother from the Middle East. And he told me, and remember, this is the 90s, he labeled himself, because this is how they were encouraged as white on the census. But he has a very different, and he didn't look white to me. He had a very different experience racially in this country than someone who does visibly appear white. So I think we've passed that now. There's a colleague who I sort of mentored years ago named Dr. Gigi Awad. I think she's at Michigan. She's a Middle Eastern woman. And she studies this a lot.
她实际上在我出版的一本关于多元化和心理健康的书里发表了一个章节。我认为我们仍然需要更多地了解该人群的经历。所以这是我想研究的一件事。我想研究的另一件事是，我想要一个更大的样本，因为我想通过公平的样本量来理解——我们第一轮的子样本大小相对相等——我想要做一个更大的样本，并使其分布更加均匀。然后我想要一个更大的认同为LGBTQAI的儿童样本。我们这次确实在数据中代表了那个样本。
She actually published a chapter in a book I put out about diversity and mental health. And I think we still have to gain more insight into what is the experience of that population. So that's one thing I want to study. Another thing I want to study is I want to get a larger sample because I want to understand through equitable sample sizes, which we had, you know, our sub samples were relatively equal in size in the first iteration, I want to do a larger sample and have it more, even more equitably distributed. Then I want a larger sample of kids who identify as LGBTQAI. We did have that sample represented in our data this time.
我们想再做一次，并拥有一个更大的样本。所以我认为我只是想更深入地了解，当你观察更多的年轻人时，我们是否会开始看到一些差异出现，而这些差异可能是我们在Acoma项目最初的3000名年轻人样本中没有看到的。而且确保我们在下一轮研究中代表阿拉伯/MENA社区对我来说非常重要。还有什么您想让我们的听众了解关于Acoma或Maddie项目的事情吗？有什么我忽略了没问您的吗？
We want to do it again and have a larger sample. So I think I just want to get more into the meat of understanding when you look at more young people, are we going to start to see some differences emerge that maybe, we at the Accoma Project didn't see what our initial sample of 3,000 young people. And it's really important to me to make sure that we're representing the Arab MENA community in the next iteration of the study. Anything else you want our listeners to know about Acoma or the Maddie Project, anything I didn't, that I neglected to ask you?
不，我认为您问的问题非常棒。总是浮现在我脑海中的事情，也是为什么我们在Acoma的研究对我如此有意义的原因，就是来自学术医学界，获得研究资金来做这种工作、专注于这个群体是一个巨大的挑战。我的希望总是，每次我有机会——再次感谢您提供这个平台——谈论它。这只是恳求那些掌权并有能力做到这一点的人增加资金。
No, I think you asked wonderful questions. The thing that always comes to me, which is why our research at Accoma is so meaningful for me, is that coming from academic medicine, it was such a challenge to get research funding to do this kind of work, to focus on this population. And my hope is always, every time I have an opportunity, again, thank you for this platform, to talk about it. It is just to sort of beg and plead with folks who are in power and have the capacity to do this to increase the funding
不，我觉得你问的问题非常棒。我一直以来的想法，也是为什么我们在Accoma的研究对我如此有意义的原因，是因为在学术医学领域，获得研究资金来开展这类工作、关注这一群体是一项巨大的挑战。我每次有机会——再次感谢你提供这个平台——谈论这件事时，我的希望总是恳求那些有权力和能力的人增加资金投入。
so that other folks out here who are interested in the mental health of diverse young people also have an opportunity to generate knowledge. So we can answer some of the questions that we've taken a staff answering today. That's the only other thing I would add. Well, I want to thank you so much for joining me today and congratulate you on this wonderful grant that you've been given. Thank you so much for having me. This has been a joy and a pleasure, and I love my colleagues at APA. You all are wonderful. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.Speakingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your
这样，其他对多元化年轻人的心理健康感兴趣的人也有机会创造知识。这样我们就能回答一些我们今天已经着手回答的问题。这就是我唯一要补充的。嗯，非常感谢您今天加入我的节目，并祝贺您获得了这笔宝贵的资助。非常感谢您的邀请。这是一次愉快而美妙的经历，我爱我在美国心理学会的同事们。你们都很棒。谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 www.SpeakingofPsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。
podcast. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe. and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop, so it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards.
如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。 《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目。我是 Kim Mills。在 Ralph's 享受更多省钱方式，例如每个过道的低价商品。下载 Ralph's 应用程序，您每周都可以通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。此外，您还可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑最多可节省 1 美元。在 Ralph's，您每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励，因此每天都能轻松省钱，获得优惠和奖励。
Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Ralph's SoCal 已有 150 多年的历史。优惠可能因州而异。燃油限制适用。详情请参阅网站。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。